[موسيقى]
موجز الاخبار اهلا بكم افاد مراسل الجزيره
بوقوع اشتباكات عنيفه بين الجيش والدعم
السريع في منطقه الجريف شرق في الخرطوم
بحري شرق العاصمه السودانيه واضاف مراسلنا
ان دويا انفجارات قويه سمعت تزامنا مع
تحليق طائرات حربيه وسط الخرطوم وفي محيط
القصر الجمهوري دوت اصوات عنيفه لاسلحه
ثقيله استخدمت في الاشتباكات في الاثناء
قال الجيش في بيان ان من وصفهم بالمتمردين
هاجموا منطقه الخرطوم بحري العسكريه
ومنطقه العاصمه العسكريه مؤكدا انه صدى
الهجوم
وكان وزير الخارجيه الكيني الفريد موتو
قال في مقابله مع الجزيره ان بلاد تشعر
بقلق من احتمال تفكك السودان وتحوله الى
جيوب صغيره واضاف ان بلاده لا تريد
للسودان ان يتحول الى ساحه حرب بالوكاله
حذر فرحان حق نائب المتحدث باسم الامين
العام للامم المتحده من ان استمرار الصراع
في السودان سيؤدي الى زياده عدد من يعانون
انعدام الامن الغذائي وان عددها هؤلاء قد
يصل الى 19 مليون شخص خلال الاشهر المقبله
قال مسؤولون في مستشفى احمد قاسم بالخرطوم
بحري للجزيره ان المواد الطبيه الخاصه
بمرضى غسل الكلى على وشك النفاذ كما اضاف
مختصون طبيون ان خروج مستشفيات عده من
الخدمه زاد من الطلب على المستلزمات
الطبيه
افاد مراسل الجزيره ان السلطات الاوكرانيه
اعلنت حاله التاهب الجوي في العاصمه كييف
تزامن هذا مع اعلان نائب وزير الدفاع
الاوكراني ان القوات الروسيه تحاول
السيطره على باخمد بالكامل بحلول التاسع
من مايو ايار الجاري وكانت وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه اعلنت انها بدات هجوما جديدا
لسيطره على المدينه
وكان رئيس مجموعه فاجنارياف غيني قد اعلن
انسحاب مقاتليه من مدينه باخمت اعتبارا من
العاشر من الشهر الجاري بسبب نقص الذخيره
في مقاطعه زبروجيا جنوبي اوكرانيا نقلت
وكاله تاسع عن السلطات المواليه لروسيا
انها تتوقع بدء الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد
خلال ايام هذا واعلن القائم باعمال حاكم
المقاطعه الموالي لروسيا عن اجلاء سكان
بعيدا عن منازلهم بسبب تكثيف القوات
الاوكرانيه للقصف عليها
اعلنت سلطات الطوارئ الروسيه انه تمت
السيطره على حريق اندلع في منشاه النفطيه
باقليم كراسن ودار بعد تعرضها لهجوم
بطائره مسيره وهذا الهجوم هو الثاني على
نفس المنشاه النفطيه خلال 24 ساعه
قال وزير الخارجيه الروسيه ان الهجوم على
الكرملين عمل عدائي لافتا الى ان بلاده
سترد بما سماها خطوات محدده وملموسه
ختام الموجز الى اللقاء